y aura-t-il des pommes de terre pour
agrémenter votre raclette cet hiver les
producteurs redoutent la plus mauvaise
récolte depuis 2000 moins 20% de
production et des pertes estimés à 200
millions d'euros les prix pourraient
donc être révalués c'est ce que nous
explique ce producteur de Saint-Pater ne
raconte interviewé par Florent Clavel
chez Alexis Gruson on est en pleine
période d'arrachage sur 17 hectares des
pommes de terre à perte de vue celle-là
deviendront des frites transformées dans
son laboratoire sauf que cette année il
y en aura peut-être un peu moins à la
cantine la faute à une production en
baisse la récolte 2022 bon bah se
présente bien malgré une baisse de
production quand même entre 15 à 30%
selon les variétés 15 à 30% de moins
c'est du jamais vu pour le jeune
agriculteur installé depuis 10 ans à
saint-paternaire à Caen en cause une
sécheresse et des températures record
cet été malgré l'arrosage que qu'on a pu
mettre en place
c'est aussi la température qui a fait
que la pomme de terre c'est pas
développée comme il faut quoi et comme
tout ce qui est rare et cher les cours
de la pomme de terre sont naturellement
en hausse Alexis lui a fait le choix de
ne répercuter que l'augmentation des
coûts de production sa priorité en cette
période de chute des rendements c'est de
conserver sa centaine de clients locaux
supermarché cantine ou particulier moi
je veux pas aller tout vendre tout de
suite comme ça parce que il y a du prix
où ceci on va éviter je vais dire de
reprendre de nouveaux clients on va
voilà ce qu'ils vont venir on va quand
même essayer de les servir mais je veux
vraiment garder
de la pomme de terre pour les clients
tout au long de l'année quoi avec ce
trou d'air dans la production
l'agriculteur est aujourd'hui forcée une
gestion prudente des emplois sont aussi
en jeu pour produire ces 650 tonnes de
pommes de terre par an Alexis gruzon
fait travailler quatre salariés et des
saisonniers